schneiden sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
des camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrug schützen die abkassieren wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's
das sind die spektakulärsten des camps
und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp
dieses mal kollisionen auf der
überholspur
geniale fahrgemeinschaften
wüstenschiffe auf der autobahn und
einparken in einem zug
[Musik]
eile mit weile
das überholen gehört zu den
gefährlichsten fahrmanöver
ungeduld ist dabei ein schlechter
ratgeber in
einer unübersichtlichen kurve
können fehleinschätzungen böse enden auf
einer zweispurigen straße ist eben kein
platz für einen flotten dreier was soll
denn das
deshalb lieber nicht auf risiko spielen
diesen fahrer scheint der gegenverkehr
nicht zu interessieren erst im letzten
moment zieht er rechts rüber um gleich
wieder zum überholen auszuscheren ein
entgegenkommen der suv muss ihn
ausweichen und überschlägt sich mehrfach
eine schlecht einsehbaren kurve auf
einer landstraße hier sollte man nicht
überholen
selbst wenn man auf zwei reifen fahren
kann der rowdy schrammt den wagen vor
sich einen frontalzusammenstoß mit der
kamera kann er gerade noch vermeiden
rechts überholen ist bis auf wenige
ausnahmefälle verboten auf keinen fall
darf man den standstreifen zum überholen
benutzen hier sehen sie warum
[Musik]
das angefahrene auto sich durch die
leitplanke und rutschte über die
gegenfahrbahn
dieser unfall hätte verdammt böse enden
können klarer fall von glück im unglück
auf zwei rädern sollte man besonders
vorausschauend fahren
stattdessen fährt dieser biker einen
anderen um der gerade links abbiegen
will
das hat bestimmt weh getan
[Musik]
sankt petersburg in russland
auf dieser dicht befahrenen straße ist
die doppelt durchgezogene linie klar zu
erkennen heißt überholen verboten für
solche spitzfindigkeiten hat der fahrer
weiter vorn keinen nerv er will den lkw
vor sich unbedingt überholen
mal rechts mal
links da steht ein linksabbieger
die folge ein heftiger zusammenstoß
die zarafa überholt wie ein verrückter
man könnte sagen er hat es darauf
angelegt
[Applaus]
schau dir das an
sind sie bescheid sie hätten sich oder
jemand anderen umbringen können haben
sie irgendwas genommen ich meine es
ernst ich habe ein kind dabei und es
sind auch noch andere unterwegs
vielleicht war die schleuderpartie ja
eine wertvolle lektion für die zukunft
andere länder andere sitten
im ausland zu fahren kann eine
herausforderung sein zum beispiel wenn
linksverkehr herrscht oder andere regeln
gelten als zu hause all die seltsamen
straßenschilder und fahrzeuge ganz schön
verzwickt
hier einige besonders exotische
fahrerlebnisse
in indien gelten für motorradfahrer
scheinbar nicht so strenge regeln vielen
anderen ländern wer braucht schon feste
schuhe die stören nur beim gas geben und
dieser schnurrbart ist ein erstklassiger
fliegenfänger
chinas antike stadt julia roll lockt
touristen mit dieser 600 jahre alten
bogen brücke für fußgänger
diese kulturbanausen sind jedoch zu faul
zum laufen und wollen mit ihrem
geländewagen rauffahren klappt aber
nicht der polizei wird das gar nicht
gefallen
[Musik]
absolut genial ist dagegen diese idee
hier im dschungel gibt es kaum gute
straßen um von a nach b zu kommen aber
schienen und motorräder ein bisschen
tüfteln fertig ist die bike bahn
zurückbleiben bitte
in kambodscha bricht diese gut gelungen
backpacker zu ihrem nächsten ziel auf
die dorfbewohner winden noch mal
freundlich zum abschied und schon geht
es los
[Musik]
was für ein spaß aber was kommt denn da
gegenverkehr sie schaffen gerade noch
rechtzeitig den absprung
[Musik]
willkommen zur jährlichen parade der
nacktradler in london sie nutzen dem
einzigen sonnentag im jahr um sich den
wind um die nase wehen zu lassen
herrlich dieses gefühl von freiheit auf
der haut
man könnte meinen dass russische bonbon
zum tüv prüft weder karosserie noch
fahrwerk noch sitze noch türen
[Musik]
dieser typ hat die ultimative idee wozu
ein sperriges lenkrad ein
schraubenschlüssel tut doch auch
[Musik]
der himalaya hier findet man einige der
höchsten berggipfel der welt allen voran
den mount everest aber vorsicht je höher
man kommt desto weniger sauerstoff gibt
es und mit wenig sauerstoff im gehirn
verliert man schnell das gleichgewicht
[Musik]
zum glück ist er nicht in hang
hinuntergestürzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in pakistan will dieser herr beweisen
dass er noch immer einiges auf dem
kasten hat
ein geistiger tiefflieger
[Musik]
ab auf die autobahn
statistisch gesehen sind autobahnen die
sichersten straßen aber auch die am
meisten befahrenen
wie gemacht also für jede menge drama
hier gibt's paukenschläge
pirouetten
querschläger und sogar züge
drei spuren verleiten so manchen dazu
auf der straße auto tetris zu spielen
dieser fahrer drängelt sich von lücke zu
locker und schubst einen anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer dabei zur seite
[Applaus]
wenn die polizei das spitz kriegt heißt
es für den rüpel game over
hier eine lektion für alle die meinen
der seitenstreifen seit zum überholen
nein ist er nicht er ist für notfälle
und sollte deshalb frei gehalten werden
wer sich trotzdem durch mogelt muss sich
früher oder später vor dem gesetz
verantworten
[Musik]
dieser lkw muss wohl doch in die andere
richtung
wie verhält man sich in so einem fall
auf der autobahn
jedenfalls nicht so
[Musik]
laut stellen man sucht sich eine spur
aus bremst ab und stellt sich an ganz
simpel doch manche haben es immer eilig
achtung schneller da vorne
[Musik]
auch wenn man unter zeitdruck steht
für eine spur sollte man sich trotzdem
entscheiden
ein geheimtipp für sparfüchse
warten bis der fahrer vor einem gezahlt
hat und dann nichts wie hinterher
vergessen sie das wieder
[Musik]
oder man verleiht seinem unmut über die
maut anders ausdruck zum beispiel indem
man ein kamel hinten am fahrzeug fest
bindet name und telefonnummer gut
sichtbar im führerhäuschen platzieren
und sich dann vom acker machen im
idealfall zahlt das kamel die mautgebühr
in naturalien
braver junge
und hier noch was fürs herz
dieser streuner ist auf der autobahn
gestrandet und die autos rauschen
rücksichtslos an die vorbei diese frau
fasst sich ein herz sie rettet den hund
und trägt ihn auf händen in sicherheit
was für ein glückspilz
[Musik]
manche unfälle sind wirklich nicht
vorherzusehen
[Applaus]
die fußgänger bleiben verschont der baum
hat es offenbar nur auf die autos
abgesehen
vor zurück passt
beim einparken trennt sich die spreu vom
weizen
[Applaus]
ups falsche pedal
die autos werden aber auch immer größer
manche wissen einfach wie's geht
dieser lkw fahrer scheint dagegen den
falschen job erwischt zu haben
[Musik]
jeder parkplatz hat eine ein- und
ausfahrt es gibt markierungen damit sich
jeder zurecht findet aber ehrlich wozu
das ganze warum nicht den direkten weg
nehmen so wie dieser fahrer
[Musik]
mit einem hechtsprung in die parklücke
voila
[Musik]
hier würde man am liebsten selbst das
steuer übernehmen
[Musik]
aber wozu rangieren die beiden damen
haben eine viel bessere idee
einfach das tonnenschwere auto anheben
geht irgendwie nicht
aber da naht hilfe so sind nur noch 500
kilo für jeden am ende schafft es doch
noch jemand in die parklücke auf die
herkömmliche art
[Musik]
wer in london einen parkplatz ergattert
kann sich glücklich schätzen und dann
auch noch mitten in der innenstadt so
schön um wahr zu sein
ob sie es bis ladenschluss schafft na ja
gerade so
[Musik]
ärgerlich wenn einem der parkplatz vor
der nase weggeschnappt wird
diese new yorkerin setzt zum
trommelfeuer an
könnte ja sein dass der fahrer den
parkplatz wieder freigibt wenn sie nur
lange genug klopft
bei ihm stößt sie auf taube ohren
aber vielleicht kann sie sich als
straßenmusikerin etwas dazuverdienen
der will nur dass dieses theater endlich
aufhört
als fahranfänger hat man es nicht leicht
beim kleinsten problemen schaut einem
gleich die ganze öffentlichkeit auf die
finger dabei sind ein paar
anlaufschwierigkeiten völlig normal kopf
hoch übung macht den meister
[Musik]
die autos werden immer größer und damit
die parklücken immer enger mit etwas
augenmaß sieht man schnell dass das
knapp wird der fahrer versucht trotzdem
[Musik]
und selbst danach im auto fest ein
klassiker aber not macht bekanntlich
erfinderisch und dieser hält nimmt
einfach den notausgang
[Musik]
2 gegen vier räder
echte biker schwören auf zwei räder um
ihr inneres gleichgewicht zu finden ein
himmlisches vergnügen man gibt gas und
fühlt sich frei
ähnlich argumentieren radfahrer ob auf
oder abseits der straße man bleibt fit
und ist an der frischen luft
lebt aber auch gefährlich
mit dem fahrrad kommt man selbst im
dichtesten verkehr schnell voran die
gefahren mit dem tempo rechnen die
anderen verkehrsteilnehmer nicht
zweiräder werden leicht übersehen
auch von anderen zweiradfahrer
ein kalter wintermorgen mit vereisten
straßen selbst für motorradfahrer ist
das zu cool vorsichtig bremsen
zu spät der fahranfänger verletzt sich
zwar nicht bei dem sturz aber jetzt muss
er das schwere motorrad wieder
aufrichten
ein netter autofahrer packt mit an
[Musik]
motorradfahrer sollten stets mit dem
unvorhersehbaren rechnen
[Musik]
und immer das licht einschalten
damit so etwas nicht passiert
immer mehr männer im mittleren alter
steigen vom auto aufs rad um
eigentlich kein problem
rad fahren verlernt man ja nicht sagt
man zumindest
oder doch regel nummer eins ein zweirad
steht nicht von allein wie wär's mit
stützrädern für den anfang
[Gelächter]
als radfahrer ist man der natur viel
näher
manchmal vielleicht zu nah merkel ein
helm schützt nicht nur bei einem unfall
sondern auch vor aggressiven vögeln
[Musik]
dieser mann könnte ebenfalls einen
kopfschutz gebrauchen in china gibt es
zwar die helmpflicht für motorradfahrer
aber kaum jemand hält sich daran der
vogel scheint nach helfen zu wollen
kleine schläge auf den hinterkopf
[Musik]
auf dem rad bergab zu fahren macht spaß
bergauf dagegen weniger diese
baumaschine kommt da gerade recht die
autofahrer dahinter scheinen leicht
irritiert
[Musik]
dann eben nicht
dieser clip hier beweist frau kann auch
auf zwei rädern große ladungen
transportieren sowas ist natürlich
streng verboten aber immerhin trennt sie
ihre mit
[Musik]
dumm und dümmer
beim fahren muss der mensch blitzschnell
lebenswichtige entscheidungen treffen
als farb tauglich gilt man aber schon ab
einem iq von über 70 nur wer prüft das
überhaupt
bei diesen bildern könnte man sich
jedenfalls glatt mit selbstfahrenden
autos am freunden
auf der autobahn gibt es mehrere spuren
für eine fahrtrichtung das sollte man
eigentlich wissen und trotzdem passiert
immer wieder so etwas
geisterfahrer
das war knapp in deutschland blühen
geisterfahrern im extremfall bis zu fünf
jahre haft
dieser ältere herr hat sich irgendwie
auf die autobahn verirrt vielleicht
nimmt er auch nur eine abkürzung
die polizei stoppt den rentner auf
abwegen der will seinen gefährlichen
ausflug zwar gern fortsetzen aber nichts
da die beamten eskortieren den mann
sicher nach hause
[Musik]
straßen sind für autos dar für fußgänger
gibt es gehwege
diese frau hat das mit der
gleichberechtigung im straßenverkehr
offenbar falsch verstanden
ihr entschlossener gang sagt komm mir
nicht in die quere offenbar mit erfolg
[Musik]
und jetzt eine wahrhaft zirkusreife
nummer
[Musik]
zwei pedalritter beim lanzenstechen
gleich nochmal weil's so schön war
[Musik]
hinten auf dem moped herumzuturnen ist
keine gute idee schon gar nicht mit t
shirt und flip flops und zwar deshalb
zum glück haben die beiden nur ein paar
schrammen davon getragen
[Musik]
was hängt denn da aus dem auto die dame
am steuer des wagens bemerkt das hupen
der anderen verkehrsteilnehmer nicht
anscheinend ist sie heute schwer von
begriff es braucht einiges an
überzeugungsarbeit bis sie das problem
versteht
die dame hat nach dem tanken vergessen
den zapfhahn abzuziehen dieser nette
biker hilft
zum schluss gibt es noch ein paar
höhepunkte aus der verrückten welt des
straßenverkehrs
[Musik]
ob mit oder ohne das kann fahren sie
bitte immer vorsichtig